my son's four teams and we're having
this conversation about when he plays in
sporting about you go full-out or do you
not and I see sometimes in him that when
he's out on the field he doesn't play
full out and I'll have an excuse like my
leg hurts or my arm hurts or something
happened the coach was unfair the
referee was unfair and what happens with
people is we tend to go out into the
world and we look for those sort of
excuses about why things aren't the way
we want them and when you do that you
lose all your power in life when you
start focusing on the external on the
excuses you lose your power or people
believe they are creatures of
circumstance that means that the life
happens to them rich people are creators
of circumstance there is no more
destructive belief in the world and to
think that life happens to you the first
thing you do is you play what I call the
blame game you stop blaming everybody
but why you don't have what you want
you'll blame the government you'll grin
your family you blame your spouse you'll
blame your boss you'll blame the economy
you'll blame the people on Wall Street
which probably deserve some blame but
you'll blame anybody and everybody when
you think the world happens to you
you're powerless that's what complain
does the second thing you do is you
justify it is because because the
economy stinks it's because people are
unfair to me it's because money doesn't
really matter anyway
third this is the worst one of all they
complain I hate these people that what
you focus on expands gets bigger and
what you focus on you attract because
you move towards it so here's what
happens when you're complaining what are
you focusing on all the in your life so
guess what happens to you you become a
giant
magnate get the picture I don't want to
be around because they attracted to you
you gotta get away from them because
when hears from playing like that you -
it's the worst of all
that's what complained us you just
watched two amazing clips from Jordan
Belfort take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]